the Iron Dome is hailed as the world's
most effective air defense system
boasting an interception success rate of
90% according to Israel but recent
events are challenging that
perception hamas's surprise attack is
exposing the system's vulnerabilities
the Iron Dome can detect Rockets fired
from 43 Mi or 70 km away it relies on a
radar unit that attacks when a missile
is launched and relays information about
its speed and trajectory to the control
unit the brains the system which rapidly
assesses what kind of projectile is in
the air and where it could potentially
land using Advanced algorithms harmless
trajectories are ignored however if the
control unit believes it's heading for a
populated area or an area of strategic
importance the launcher fires missiles
to intercept the enemy rocket by
exploding near it while not making
direct contact with it each iron doome
system often referred to as a battery
consists of three or four launchers each
equipped with 20 missiles the system is
mobile so can move to wherever it's
needed 10 batteries are placed
strategically throughout the country
each defending an area of up to 60
square mil they don't protect every inch
of Israel's total area of 9,000 square
miles instead they're strategically
place to protect populated areas and key
assets if they didn't exist Israeli
tanks would have to roll into Gaza
immediately to stop the rocket fire like
they did in 2009 today the US has
invested 2.6 billion in the Iron Dome
defense system there's Iron Dome being
fired up all around us right now it's
Illuminating the sky here the Iron Dome
has been the backbone of Israel's
multi-layer defense since 2011 with
thousands of successful interceptions
however that backbone appeared to crack
on October 7th 2023 right now a massive
barrage of rockets coming off of the
Gaza
Strip This is an effort by Hamas and
Islam Jad to overwhelm is Israel's
missile defense system but whatever
happened in the early hours of this
morning the Iron Dome was not able to
stop this barrage the Iron Dome was not
able to stop this barrage Hamas
Unleashed an astonishing number of
rockets from Gaza they claim 5,000 in a
span of 20 minutes the Israeli Defense
Forces put the number at
2200 even taking the lower figure the
intensity of this attack is remarkable
when compared to the 50-day conflict in
2014 during which a total of 4,000
Rockets were fired from Gaza into Israel
while the Israeli Defense Forces have
not disclosed the number of rockets
intercepted video evidence shows Rockets
raining down on indiscriminate targets
leaving buildings destroyed and hundreds
of people dead Iran State Affiliated nor
news mockingly described the Iron Dome
as nothing but a dome of straw above a
sand castle the iron Do's toir
interceptors are neither infinite nor
cheap costing around $50,000 each in
contrast hamas's rudimentary Kasam
rockets that are fueled by mixture of
sugar and everyday fertilizer cost 300
to $800 per launch the sheer number of
rockets Hamas was able to secretly amass
has led to questions how did Israeli
intelligence fail to detect the growing
stockpile it has one of the most
advanced intelligence agencies in the
world and works closely with the CIA was
Israel too preoccupied with other
threats like the more potent Hezbollah
these are the questions that isra
officials have so far failed to answer
the US responded swiftly to the surprise
attacks by bolstering Israel's depleted
Iron Dome interceptors since 2014 major
American military contractor Ron has
partnered with Israel's Raphael advaned
defense systems to craft components for
the Tamir Interceptor missiles while the
intention has been to support Israel
this collaboration has also enhanced us
defense capabilities two batteries have
been supplied to the US Army but faith
in the Iron Dome isn't Universal MIT
Professor Ted pel who is an expert on
Missile technology believes the Iron
Dome is not as reliable as it seems he
estimates its success rate during the
November 2012 conflict between Israel
and Hamas might have been as low as 5%
or less his evidence photographic
documentation of missile exhaust flight
paths for the Iron Dome to neutralize an
enemy rocket effectively it should
confront it headon however Professor
pel's Research indicates the missiles
often attacked from the side which is a
problem or from behind which is also
ineffective in MIT technology review he
elaborates if the Interceptor hits the
back end of the rocket the Warhead will
almost certainly go onto the ground and
explode Professor posel suggested that
the Iron Dome radar tracking and
guidance system is not working and this
sparked significant controversy Israel's
Ministry of Defense dismissed his claims
as baseless maintaining their confidence
Ence in the Iron Dome I reached out to
Professor pel for his current take on
the iron dome's Effectiveness but
haven't yet heard back an intriguing
sentiment from a 2021 foreign policy
article suggests Israel's air defenses
May one day not be enough to hinder
volumes of rockets Israel won't admit
this but there is a strategic Peak for
this technology while the Iron Dome has
kept Israel citizens safe for over a
decade it's clearly not infallible the
recent attacks reveal the tracks in the
Iron Dome underscoring that even the
world's most advanced defense system has
its
limits as we discuss Advanced defense
Technologies like the Iron Dome one
can't help but wonder about the
historical events that necessitate such
Innovations I've recently been binging
curiosity stream which has award-winning
documentaries about history I'm
currently watching the history of mad
the Israeli foreign Defense Agency that
was founded to guarantee the ongoing
existence of Israel you cannot help have
a true reading of the history of Israel
the history of the whole world without
understanding the secret history of its
intelligence Services curiosity stream
has thought-provoking and original
documentaries you won't find anywhere
else spanning science nature technology
military history music food and more if
you love to learn check out
curiositystream.com
newthink the link is in my description
or scan the QR code on your screen and
use my promo code news think to save 25%
off
thanks for watching for news think I'm
Cindy pal